do you think we're too sensitive as
society particularly on the internet
i could show you a couple of the the
tweets i've had to see over the last
couple of days
and they might all seem fine um
or like it's easy to brush it off but in
the context of like dealing with this
for
i don't know how many like over 10 years
and a lot of it and sometimes it's huge
pylons
um it it feels very different
another analogy i have heard sometimes
is like um
if somebody steps on your foot by
accident and you respond really
negatively
they may say like why are you so upset
like why are you so sensitive
like i just accidentally stepped on your
foot like you don't even like get upset
at me
but if you're the person who's put got
stepped on and you've been stepped on
like thousands of times and your foot is
sore already
then when this other person like
actually steps on you
it already hurts and it's a huge pattern
of problematic behavior and hurt that
you have accrued
and so the responses feel different they
feel mismatched and like both sides may
feel upset at the other because
they're just operating from different
contexts
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks i am your
co-host
zach grauman today we are talking about
the future of censorship
with a woman incredible woman named
tracy chao i just had a conversation
with her
she is the founder of a new app she just
launched it called
block party and what it does is right
now just on twitter but it
allows you to simply filter out crappy
comments
and hateful comments or mean comments or
annoying comments you don't want to see
on twitter
and it's user empowered so it's not on
the big tech company to do it it's on
you and we talk about not just her app
which is pretty fascinating but
censorship in big tech and this new
world that we're creating that lacks
social norms and i learned
so much by talking to tracy i said this
on the pod but
i feel like i she hit me over the head
three or four times with like a
different perspective on how we view
censoring out offensive speech on the
internet and it's
uh it's something we're gonna have to
deal with as a society and particularly
as a younger generation this problem is
not going away and so you are going to
enjoy this one i mean that because i
enjoyed it i learned a ton
so tune in guys the future of censorship
with the founder of block party
tracy chow here on yank speaks
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks in our
newest episode
the future of and we are talking about
the future of
censorship today and we have honestly
let me ask you guys
every time we bring on a badass
entrepreneur i get very excited because
i love people who build things i think
building things are hard
specifically if someone can find a way
to create an organization a company in a
revenue model that makes the world a
better
place so i'm excited we have the prime
example of that
tracy chao who's the founder and ceo of
block party today tracy
welcome to the future of how are you
thanks for being here thanks so much for
having me super excited
let's start with you your background's
fascinating i know that you you have a
like an engineering coding background um
which kudos to you that's
i suck at learning languages i've been
told in coding is like learning another
language so tell us about you
tracy and welcome my background um when
some people look at it
it feels like the quintessential silicon
valley background so i grew up in the
bay area
both my parents were software engineers
they have phds in computer science so i
grew up
in the 80s in a house that had just lots
of computers and computer parts
everywhere
um i didn't know what all that was back
then
also computers were not as sexy it was
just like there's like big crt monitors
um black screens green text kind of
matrix
looking my grandpa and my dad were
engineers so this stuff was around they
sounded less
they sound less smart than your parents
were similar
yeah so i had a very silicon valley
upbringing um
i grew up in the bay area went to school
mountain view
my high school actually invested in the
seed round of snap which is
funny yes it's very i did grow up in so
much
i did um and i went to stanford
university
not really knowing exactly what i wanted
to do but being in that environment was
just very easy to get drawn into the
world of tech so i have
um two engineering degrees from stanford
electrical engineering computer science
and almost naturally got pulled into the
valley
working in tech companies um did
internships at google and facebook when
i was in university and
when i graduated um worked at quora the
question answer site very early i was
the second engineer hired onto the team
um pinterest i joined when it was
roughly 10 people
so i got to see a few of these companies
from the ground up really
um and so i have that background in
engineering having built products
um as a side note on all of that though
despite the fact that it felt like i
just had this straight pathway into
silicon valley tech and startups
it wasn't that easy and in hindsight now
i realize that a lot of it has to do
with the fact that
i'm a woman and there's still quite a
lot of
gender bias and discrimination and so
despite
my entire background seeming like i was
being groomed for this
i got a lot of pushback for entering the
field um a lot of people kind of
discouraging me from
being technical saying things like your
technical background make you great for
recruiting or great for design or great
for sales and marketing
all these different things are totally
important parts of the ecosystem but
it was just this expectation that women
would not become engineers not really be
working in product
were a lot of your classes all guys at
stanford
mostly there was usually at least one
other
woman or two others but it was the sort
of environment where
if i went to go see a professor they
would recognize me as one of the three
women in the class i remember talking to
one
professor once who was just like oh like
oh you yeah you're the asian girl the
class was also a white girl and a black
girl it's like well that's
that's great thanks
um so that subtext is relevant
um to the work i was doing in
engineering and products i started to
understand the lack of diversity
and representation on the teams i was
working on had very material impacts on
the products we were building
and in particular i was working on the
social consumer products that had
people users generating content
interacting with each other
and i really came to appreciate how all
of our product decisions
were embedding the biases that we
carried as humans
writing the code and even though there
is
an instinct for folks to think of code
as being neutral
for that idea of the technology platform
as being neutral like it's just code
it's just
algorithms uh from that perspective of
being a software engineer helping to
design
a lot of these companies from the ground
up the sort of product constructs within
them
working on things like home feed and
search and recommendations
for both cora and pinterest i really
came to see how
we embedded all of our biases into these
products we took our best
guesses our intuitions in designing our
products and thinking through what
people would want to see
but we're very limited based on
our own experiences some of these new
and innovative like the pioneers like
the trailblazing aspect of tech
um they are building new systems new
ways of operating right but the problem
is if the only people that have access
at the ground floor these new
trailblazing
uh technologies to say are
frankly rich white dudes that look and
talk like myself
and that's it then we end up just
building maybe a slightly better but
still
just you know just as any in equal
world that we have we build another one
right it just kind of reflects the same
thing
it's just in a different way one of the
um very key experiences i had earlier at
quora
was that even when the site was only
maybe a few thousand users
um i was already getting harassed on the
site
and there's different ways to define
what harassment is and
people would argue like well that's not
technically harassment
my experience on the receiving end was
there was someone interacting with me in
ways that i did not like
that were very annoying and i wanted it
to stop
and so when i joined quora as an
engineer
the first thing i built was the block
button so i wanted this person to stop
being able to comment on my answers
up on my answers message me i was very
excited to make this person the first
person ever blocked
on quora were you assigned to do that or
you're like came in engineering you're
like no no this needs to happen
in the early days the road map is a lot
more flexible
and people on the team will often
have influence on what gets built next
based on how strongly they feel about
something there's a referendum for the
overall
yeah or just like personal conviction
about something and for me it was also
um my first job coming out of school so
i was relatively
junior and wanted to pick off something
that was
a smaller task at first just to get
going and it felt like it recently
useful feature that was not too big
that i could fight off as a first task
um
but i'm pretty sure that the block
button would not have been built as
early as it was
if i hadn't been pushing for it and
wanting it so personally
so these different threads of my
background i have the engineering side
product
building side and also the experience of
even from very early dealing with
harassment or unwanted content or just
wanting to have a little bit more
control over my own experience
those things have led into me building
block party
another aspect of it is like it's so
entangled um
having worked on these products in these
teams
i came to feel very strongly that we
needed more diversity and inclusion
in tech workforces and
over the last i guess 10 or so years
have done quite a bit of activism around
diversity and inclusion in tech
and in doing so have built a bit more of
a platform
primarily on twitter which is uh
my addictive platform of choice
and as as my platform there has grown a
little bit
it's also subjected me to more abuse and
harassment uh
which i think is not unrelated to the
fact that the people
building this platform early did not
experience it so did not build in the
sort of safeguards
right right oh interesting sandra and i
were talking about this
um when he was running for president he
was starting to get bigger he had like
he was getting to like uh he now has two
million twitter followers or so and
but he was a point where he's at like
you know 50 thousand to a hundred
thousand
and he was getting advice from people
that were a little more famous on
twitter than him
like when do you stop reading the
comments you know um
and what your point you're making it's
interesting is that i
i basically got the trickle like the
funnel effects from andrew's followers
and people followed me like by default
which was which is fun
and there's a nice community there but i
get harassed too
and it's um i think what you're saying
is like yeah as a white guy if you think
it's bad
uh in this tech world like people of
color women are getting it way worse and
i've seen i've seen that the way this
has skewed it's um
if it's built by the wrong people aren't
experiencing the prioritization like
you're saying of
building those safeguards don't start so
you create block party
tell me how it works you also i love
that you make
blocking stuff sound fun um
it's not it's not like fun by nature i
don't know so it tells how it works
sure so the idea behind block priority
is that we wanted to build
consumer tools for managing and dealing
with online harassment and
just unwanted content generally giving
people more control
over their online experience we're
starting off with tools for twitter
and the core product as it is right now
is pretty simple you sign up for block
party
you link your twitter account you set a
bunch of filtering options where you can
say
uh i need a break it's one of the names
of our modes which is like
a more restrictive study i need a break
and in this mode
um you can you can also have like uh
further rules around filtering you could
say i don't want to hear from anybody
unless they're followed by somebody i
follow
or they're a verified user or it's
somebody that i've interacted with
recently
and everyone else please filter them out
and what block party does is run in the
background to keep filtering
it will automatically mute anybody that
hasn't passed the filters
which means that you can use twitter as
normal
check your mentions check your
notifications and it's quieter
there's less of the stuff that you may
not want to deal with but everything
that's been
filtered and hidden actually ends up in
a folder on block party that you can
still check
when you want to so you could go in and
have a hate-filled day
if you really wanted to if you want to
yeah and you could check it too though
sometimes the filter you're like
too strict actually don't mind those
comments stuff like that right so
um one thing that is pretty key to
understand is people use these
public platforms in order to engage with
a wider audience that's the point of
having one of these
platforms especially twitter right words
right
yeah but a lot of other ones too like
you're trying to reach other people if
you wanted to just reach your existing
friends
you could start a group chat with them
but this is it's meant to be a different
platform um
and i certainly have benefited a lot
from
twitter as a public platform uh and i
like to engage with folks that i don't
already know
um i've heard really interesting things
from people in the comments
and there's a lot of really positive
things that come out of having a public
presence
um from for journalists it might be
hearing
tips for stories or hearing feedback on
articles they've written for politicians
maybe engaging with constituents
answering questions about policy stances
um for activists it is like reaching
more people
there's a lot of positive which is why
we're on these platforms uh
the thing is we're trying to balance it
also with the potential negative
and you may want to set your filtering
rules very high
in order to make sure you have less
likelihood of seeing
bad stuff or upsetting stuff knowing
that you'll over filter some of the good
stuff as well and so it's good then to
go into the
folder and check any potential good
stuff that got filtered
uh on the flip side sometimes you do
need to be aware of very negative things
um so i've also had the personal
experience having to deal with
more elevated stalking and harassment i
needed to be aware of what was happening
and so even if i didn't want to get
notifications uh
of comments from stalkers or harassers i
still need to check it regularly to make
sure that there's no
escalation and threat um unfortunately
there have been cases where
it rose to level of physical stalking
and so i really did need to be aware of
what was happening
so kind of like just muting
a bunch of notifications and pretending
that this content doesn't exist can also
be dangerous
and so what block party is doing is
giving
you more control over when you see this
content so you can be mentally prepared
for it
there's some time delay it doesn't feel
like it has to interrupt your day
when you do want to go look at this
stuff you're ready for it you're
choosing to go into it it's not just
messing up your tuesday right
one of the experiences i had was just
noticing
i checked twitter all throughout the day
but before i had block party running and
filtering
that just meant that any point
throughout the day i could see something
upsetting that would throw me off for a
few minutes or even more
um and i find it analogous actually too
when i walk
down the street get street harassment in
any big city
as a woman in particular very likely to
encounter some street harassment and
even if you can shake it off knowing
that it's probably harmless they're
probably not going to do anything it is
still upsetting and i had the same sort
of reaction to seeing
harassment or just unpleasant comments
um
and replies on twitter and i don't like
being subjected to that all throughout
the day and so if i can isolate it to a
certain time when i'm ready to go look
at it it's much better
well i love about the app and this just
a concept in general is putting the
control
in the user's hands as opposed to
relying on twitter and relying on
frankly like jack dorsey and his
judgment
well-intentioned if it may be uh that's
still like that's
that's top down i like the bottom up
play
censoring hate or negativity
or tone like all these things are by
definition
generally gray i mean there's certain
things i think hate speech is pretty
clearly defined
um at least from a legal standpoint but
how do you um like algorithmically like
on the back and
uh determine what's angry
what is mean yeah like there's a few
points to address here
um one that flows pretty naturally from
a couple of points you just raised
is that there's a certain level
of um restriction that platforms
would want to enforce um and so there's
that terms of service agreement where
they'll say like if you get
past this line there's like a bright red
line here no
child sexual exploitation no hate speech
of a certain form like once you get past
that line
the platforms will take your content off
um
potentially de-platform you that's a
very
severe line on the other side there's
what individuals may or may not want to
hear
that's a there's a very big space in
between those things and so from my
perspective
as soon as i see things in my my folder
on block party
are things like oh you're just like an
ugly skinny chinese girl from san
francisco
like well i don't know you need to if
you need to have your
twitter account taken away for that but
i also don't need to see it
there's no need for me to have my like
brain polluted with your crappy thoughts
so in that space there's a lot of room
for consumer choice
and the way i think about what block
party is doing in terms of filtering is
let's just give people a bit more
control over what they see it doesn't
mean that
those folks who are tweeting these nasty
things
can't do that for now or we can kind of
put that aside and say like
fine you can post these mean things um
but
i don't need to see them so this kind of
question of like
do you get distribution on your content
it's very different than do you have
freedom of speech
um and are you censored so fine you can
have freedom to
speak and i have freedom to not listen
so that's that's like a pretty big
distinction to make um
one other thing to get to is kind of
like how do you
detect this hate and so that's what i
really like
where does it does you have like a whole
list of bad words uh
does it i mean a i could probably pick
up tone and interesting things now like
what
and i'm assuming as a startup
it's your call out the gate right like i
mean you're giving people power but you
are
you and your engineers are creating the
algorithm that's determining what's bad
how does
how i'm just i'm so naive like i have no
idea how this works so
yeah where do you start there how does
that work yeah so
one thing i would say on this front is
the way that most people and platforms
conceptualize
content moderation i find flawed where
this framing of there is content and
then we're going to assess if it's good
or not and then if it's good we allow it
to go through and if it's not then we
block it this construction is over
simplistic
and flawed and there is
a better way to think about it in a more
holistic way
and so that is part of the product
philosophy behind block party that it's
not just about looking at individual
pieces of content saying it's okay
or not it's really understanding the end
user experience so
if we center the experience of somebody
who may have to deal with content coming
from all directions
people who may be also following you
across platforms or there may be a
pattern
of behavior that is problematic
a lot of people like to go to artificial
intelligence as a solution for it to say
like oh look we should be able to detect
if there's hate if we should be able to
detect if the tone is negative we should
be able to detect if there's harassment
and my take on that is you can use
ai machine learning to help in some
cases but
you'll never get all the way there
people are very creative with
harassment um there are some things
which you'll never be able to figure out
unless you have
full like context understanding
and even then like if you have like
smart people they may not understand the
context and they may not
realize there was a lot of stuff we
didn't realize in the beginning of the
ngan campaign
where the team was on a tune to like
certain racists or whatever
extreme hateful cultures and you don't
flag it early
some of the things that i've gotten i'm
almost 100 confident would not get
picked up by machine learning so things
like
i used to have an illustrated avatar of
me with
a dog there's just a cute dog that i
liked
um and the responses i got to that were
like don't accidentally eat your dog
which is obviously meant to be a racist
stereotype um i'm not even part of the
like asian subgroup
that that stereotype is directed at but
the people who are being racist don't
care
so again like it doesn't matter um
so that kind of thing ai is going to be
challenged to detect correctly and
if the way that you action on the
classification
of these um pieces of content is like we
just allow it or don't allow it then you
get into a lot of questions on is the
censorship like how do you know that
it's bad enough to remove
versus the way that block party is set
up which is just saying like
for the end user the consumer like i can
just choose to not see this stuff
i'm not not allowing you to post it um
it's more just like on my side
i can filter but i'll still see it later
and so the fact that
we have uh constructed the product such
that
you'll still see it later removes a lot
of those questions about did we get it
exactly right did we classify it exactly
correct we can say
we have tolerance for error we have
tolerance for over filtering because
it's just designed for error in its own
way right where people
right yeah so it's like i'm actually
totally okay to have it over filter
because i will see it later
all i'm doing is is like making it so
that i'll check it a few days later as
opposed to
i don't allow you to post it um and with
this kind of built into the product it
also makes it so that
um we don't even need to be that smart
with the artificial intelligence
quote unquote um we're actually using
pretty simple heuristics right now and
it turns out these heuristics like
is this user verified is this user
followed by anybody i follow like these
heuristics work really well
um you can also look at things like how
many followers does this person have
when do they create their account do
they have a profile photo set
and even very simple rules like this
work
pretty well and in the edge cases or the
cases where
there's over filtering it's okay you
just see it later
uh and so yeah like this this question
of artificial intelligence comes up a
lot everybody wants to ask like
what is your technology behind i think
there's this allure of technology being
the savior uh for all of our you know
all of our issues
one of the big takeaways i had from
studying ai and academic setting and
also building some of these models
when i worked at quora and at pinterest
is that in order to build
these models you need to understand the
problem
so you understand the domain um and then
have some understanding of what
heuristics are good so
uh i guess it does depend upon what kind
of machine learning models you're
choosing
but for some types of models it is
really like you need to understand the
domain to
figure out what features are relevant to
include in your model
um with some of the newer versions
of machine learning the um like deep
learning stuff
neural nets that are starting to become
more popular the idea is that you don't
have to pre-select what the features are
called the neuro what neural nets uh
neural net is this this is like elon
musk's like upload your conscience or is
this different
kind of yeah it took a lot of the new
like ai advances come out in the last
almost 10 years have been in neural nets
deep learning
kind of like that what people are
talking about it's just terrifying
and awesome but terrifying in some ways
it is in other ways it's not
um in a very simplistic way it's just
mathematical models so
you probably studied some things in like
even like middle school or high school
math it's like y
equals mx plus b that is a model that is
a linear model so all you're doing is
saying
we have one input feature which is your
x and your output is the y
and so that's a very simple model when
you get fancier you might have like
ax squared plus bx right plus c
so that then yeah
now we have like a few more parameters
to fit and it's a quadratic model
instead of a linear model
um other forms of like machine learning
artificial intelligence are just
different models like this where you
figure out what the structure of the
solution is and then you fit some
some like numbers some parameters in
there
but it's really just fancy math
this episode of yang speaks is brought
to you by all form guys
i'm sitting on my all form couch
right now i don't always record ads
sitting on the couch but i thought it'd
be fun for this ad
so we've talked about helix mattresses
because they're awesome mattresses but
the same
company is making amazing couches using
the awesome cushy quality they have in
their mattresses on their couch and it's
so
easy all form is awesome you can
customize your couch
or sofa using premium materials guys i
literally
got i had a cut on my leg and i put
basset tracing on it and i got it on the
couch
and i just put a little water on this
little dish soap on it and it came right
off
as if it's gone these couches don't
stain they're freaking awesome you can
assemble them yourself the color looks
great i get compliments on it all the
time i've slept on it
i've sat on it i've watched tv on it it
looks great
is cool it's well priced this thing is
freaking
awesome plus they deliver it to you you
can assemble it yourself
it's freaking fantastic they offer a
forever warranty
literally forever so to find your
perfect sofa
check out allform.com yang again
all form is offering twenty percent off
all orders for our listeners
again at allform.comyangmyth
allform.com yang
[Music]
you know my uncle worked at um at intel
for
decades and he's they always work on
really cutting edge stuff before it's
like anywhere near mainstream and his
theory like 10 years ago 15 years ago i
was like someday you're gonna be able to
look at something
buy it you want to look at something
comment on it but not actually have to
do it
um we're not there yet but that's
theoretically ideally where we can go
and maybe
to your point like you could look at
something and say i don't ever want to
see something like that again
um you know right like i don't want that
in my world is that
do you think about that stuff as an
entrepreneur in the early stages or to
you you're like hey i just need a good
product that helps people
like filter out the hate in a fun
simplistic learning way
i think there's always some level
thinking about long term and
where are we potentially heading and
also a little bit of like in the worst
case scenarios what are the things that
could go wrong
um i may do this more than other folks
maybe from doing a lot of work around
diversity and inclusion
and tech and seeing when you go off the
rails
what are the potential abuses what are
the potential worst case outcomes um
but in the immediate term short term
we need to build a useful product and
it's not that helpful to keep ruminating
about
if we're wildly successful 15 years down
the line
what happens like there's still some
thinking about it like
what is a potential path here are there
obvious bad things that we should be
steering clear of or safeguards that we
should be building in now
but it is a balance where there's a lot
that needs to be done
right now and some of the decisions
we've made around product
and engineering are let's keep things as
simple as possible
which is better in the sort of
philosophical ways we're not doing
anything
too fancy or trying to be too smart
about things
which would be difficult now in any case
with artificial intelligence you need
always data to train your models
if you don't have that data your models
are not going to be very good so we
don't have all that data right now
it's hard to get a contextualized so
when people talk about data can also be
like
data across your entire set your entire
population or the entire problem space
but then it won't be as relevant for
individual cases
and so it may not be as contextual for
my case and in order to make a model
that works really well
for me i need a lot of data from people
similar to me or
cases similar to mine we don't have all
that data
your models are just not going to be
very good and you're also limited if
you're looking at language models for
example like do you have enough in this
language
versus some other heuristics you could
use are a lot simpler so the things that
we
have used um our language agnostic
they're
actually pretty much a content agnostic
at the moment we're looking at user
features so
did you create your account recently are
you followed by someone i follow
so these things also work in all
languages which means that our product
is easier to build
it works very well and it like
scales in the sense it applies to many
more people and
all languages from the get-go instead of
having to train individual models for
each language
which probably wouldn't work that well
anyways from what i know of
how much work it takes to build these um
so always like with
any situation where you're resource
constrained which is very true of
startups
also true in some other environments
where you you just only have
so much to work with you figure it out
you can't boil the ocean
one thing you also think about like
what can we achieve with the minimal
resources we have like how do we get the
biggest bang for our buck and so if you
can
do five percent of the work but achieve
seventy percent
of like your goal do that first do the
low-hanging fruit first
instead of let's say we wanted to build
ai models
that would take a lot more work and
my opinion is that it would still be
worse outcomes than what we've achieved
so you might do like
80 more work and only get to
50 effectiveness as opposed to like 70
when you get
really simple heuristics um so it's
always this balance of like what are the
trade-offs how much work does it take
and how effective is it and i think the
approach we've taken is
a lot less work and actually more
effective than
the like kind of smart technology ai
approach which seems really shiny but
doesn't really work that well that's one
of the hardest things entrepreneurship
it was one and we had it i've had it in
a number of companies i built or helped
build and one andrew
his campaign was good one too was like
on one hand you're like okay we want to
win the presidency
we want to seriously contend for the
presidency what does that mean there's a
million pieces of that right but the
other end of the day was well
if we want to contend we have to get on
the debate stage and how do you get on
the bait stage we need 65 000 people
give us a dollar so
the goal goes to boiling the ocean
running for president to like just 65
human thousand human beings giving one
dollar
how to make that as easy possible um and
that's i think a lot of entrepreneurs
lose sight of that at times um not for a
bad reason for flakman not for lack of
ambition but maybe lack of focus at
times what it seems to be great about
block party to me is that you
use the tools
twitter already has how would it start
to work
for other platforms like facebook and
snapchat
and instagram so we have the very short
term right now which is just building on
twitter
a little bit further out we do want to
build cross platform understanding that
abuse and harassment is never limited to
just one just on twitter
you're a lot spillover you also have
very creative harassers who
mount these cross-platform attacks and
know how to navigate terms of service
one platform to the next and they take
advantage of the fact that
platforms don't really coordinate um so
we do want to go across platform
i think further out than that is
not just building on top of other
platforms that exist already and are
large and have
apis but actually defining our own
sort of safety and
trust and safety apis that
other platforms would integrate so if
you think about new social networks that
are popping up
they oftentimes don't think about
moderation
safety constructs until a little bit
later it's the last thing you're
thinking of
yeah yeah and it shouldn't be but a lot
of ways a lot of times it is yeah
right it's tricky to think too far ahead
on that front because
there won't be any abuse on your
platform if you have nobody using it
you kind of need to build a platform
that you want to use but you also need
to be thinking about what are the
potential misuse of technology so it is
a balance of
don't over engineer anything too early
but
also don't let things go off the rails
as soon as you get any kind of traction
but one thing we're thinking about for
block party is like how do we
start to define what are those safety
constructs that
all platforms should be thinking about
how do we make it easier for
new people building uh
these new social networks and new ways
of interacting to integrate
safety constructs from early on so one
analogy
i use is um with payments infrastructure
online
stripe has done a really good job of
defining
if you want to take credit card payments
online you want to payment stuff online
like you don't need to build all that
payment stuff yourself just integrate
with the stripe api and stripe
is the expert in doing all the payment
stuff so
what's nice about stripe being the
api is they help to define what are the
constructs you should care about so
there's a customer model you have plans
you have subscriptions
they make it easy for you to clarify
your thinking as a consumer of their api
so
block party uses stripe api it makes us
clean up all of our models and how we
put things in our system
because we're trying to match to what
stripe has implemented
what block party can do is kind of be
those apis for
safety moderation and
help to shape how other platforms
are thinking about moderation because in
order to integrate with us they'd have
to
map out what does it mean to mute to
block to report or whatever
apis become the sort of like dominant
constructs
for those of you who don't speak code
like myself api
is application programming interface and
let me see if i get this right it's
basically when
like i'm building a website i want to
put i want to put a spotify player
on there spotify's got an api
application programming interface that i
can go on and use i can see their code i
can act it and
i can slot it into my site where my info
is feeding with theirs and it's
it's it's some it's a form i think of
open source in a way in the sense that
it's
it's collaborative i don't know you know
about coding but i mean by getting that
right for the people that are listening
that aren't
aren't coders yeah
thanks for calling out that i i kind of
skew technical in the conversation
the simplest way to think about apis is
that you have
different computer systems that want to
talk to each other so they define a way
of talking to each other
and um you can specify
specify like what are the ways you want
to talk and it may just be
like with the stripe api for payments
it's very easy to explain like
um we just like we want to be able to
take a payment and
this is like you know that the payment
has been taken and um
what's nice then is like a site like
block party
we can take payments but we don't have
to build all the payments off ourselves
we just told stripe like hey we have a
customer that wants to take payment
can you handle it it stripe handles it
and then lets us know
okay they have paid done yeah it's all
[Music]
good
[Music]
a few decades ago private citizens used
to be just that
private and what's changed the internet
everything you've ever browned searched
watched
tweeted you name it it's all being
crawled through on the back end through
your data
it's going through third parties becomes
public record
permanently it's your record so to keep
our data
private andrew and i when we go online
we use expressvpn
there are hundreds of data brokers out
there and their sole businesses to buy
and sell your data and expressvpn
prevents them
from doing that our connection gets
rerouted through an encrypted server
and our ip address our mass so every
time i turn on expressvpn i just press a
little button
it gives me a random ip address shared
by other expressvpn
customers that is used to keep us all
private and safe it makes it more
difficult for third parties to identify
me
and harvest my data or harvest andrew's
data
it's awesome so here's the deal if you
are like us and believe that your data
should be your business
not other people's business secure
yourself with the number one rated vpn
on the market visit expressvpn.com
yang and get three extra months for free
that's expressvpn.com
yang go to expressvpn.com yang to learn
more
right now
so let's talk um you said something
really interesting before let's talk a
bit about
first amendment because i think you are
filling a void
that big tech has not done themselves um
and so this is i'm i believe in um free
speech i think it's
there's a reason it's first and i think
it's um foundational to
um civilization in many ways and or
developed civilization today and
democracy in particular but i believe
that
you can say whatever you want to extend
to you know it's
outside of let's call like what's
predefined legal hate speech um
but what i don't like about big tech is
that we've like leaned on that but we've
also
leaned the other way where we're like
but if people are free to say whatever
they want
our algorithm is still going to
distribute that nonsense
like across our platforms too um
and they're they're trying to figure it
out
they being the google facebook apples of
the world um
and what you've done is
said apple stop facebook stop trying to
in this case twitter stop trying to
be the first amendment police here and
put it on the person
you're like okay people are saying
whatever they want i'm gonna just
filter out what i'm comfortable seeing
and i don't want to distribute it and
share it in my face
is that the future in your in your
opinion where it's
it's going to be less on the the big
tech companies to
filter this out and more on us i think
people actually happy with that it's
kind of what you've done what are you
what are your thoughts there
yeah there's so many things i want to
address uh the first
is around like free speech or long
people to say what they want
um i think a very
simplistic interpretation of this is
like
yes everybody can just say what they
want and like we should aspire to that
on platforms um
and we don't put any sort of uh
restrictions on what can be posted
and that's like the truest form of free
speech in practice
because of things like abuse and
harassment many people can't actually
speak freely because they know that if
they speak they will be inundated with
harassment
and the repercussions to that are so
much that people are self-silencing and
i sense this as well like in my own
posting online i know there's certain
topics that if i
talk about them the repercussions will
be so negative that i
will wish i had not done that and so i
will preemptively hold back and so
that's not really freedom of speech then
like what you're doing is allowing
the like unchecked abuse to silence
certain people
and so even that conception of like
first amendment like you should have
freedom of speech is
flawed in that way but building on that
idea
is um this notion that
it's not just speech there are
repercussions to it
there are things that happen after the
speech
um and for a long time we've kind of
viewed
the words or media that people post
online is like that's it
and not really understanding we're not
understanding what are the ramifications
of that
we got to see on january 6th some
very clear ramifications of allowing
people to post things that they're
online it's not just that they're
sharing content with each other
it does turn into offline world
consequences
this brings me to a next point which is
that our
governance models don't understand this
so when i talk about governance it's um
both things like offline
laws so we have the constitution kind of
we've
talked about first amendment
constitution um
and other like the other laws that apply
in
physical nation states and local
jurisdictions
um but there's also sort of like the
governance of online
worlds where we don't really have the
equivalent there
um so there's laws offlines if you do
certain things that are illegal that
violate the laws
you may face repercussions for them
online we don't have
an equivalent system of governance and
we also don't have a system of
governance that
contains both offline and online worlds
together and
understands that the ramifications of
online speech can actually be
let's say murder or insurrection
and because we don't have a system of
law or governance that understands that
we're very limited
uh right now to try and appeal to
offline world
systems of governance like are there
some laws that you have
violated in the office have you like
incited an insurrection
have you incited violence and that's the
only way we take any kind of action
against
online speech whereas there's a whole
bunch of stuff that's happened
in between the online speech and like
murder
that are bad we joke about irl versus
url right like url online
irl in real life that distinction is so
blurred
right like especially in this past year
when almost all of our interactions have
been digital
yeah there's not really big difference
between things rl
weirdly even though it's online right
you but you said something i had never
thought of
and it's this concept of
basically when this first amendment was
written
and for hundreds of years it was people
would say whatever they want because it
it's just it's just noise um there
wasn't like streamlined ways to
communicate and then freedom of press
was part of it as well but now you're
talking about
um other parts of freedom of speech that
are
almost uniquely on the internet so like
it's one thing for one person to start
shouting hate speech
at the top of mountain or saying
something mean it's another thing if
they're talking to twenty thousand
hundred thousand
a million people because that's like uh
a various and it that's like an assembly
and it may not be peaceful based on that
language and now and then in the
internet you're not just talking about
words you can be talking about
pictures and videos and animation and
god knows what this problem that we're
facing is
so big that we have to reconceptualize
all of governance and i think it's a
phase shift that's as significant
as say going from
tribal communities to feudal states
or feudal states with like monarchy
to modern liberal democracies like this
is a very big transition in how
all of society functions and
just quibbling about like one particular
law
doesn't feel like it's going to get us
to where we need to be in terms of
governance
and one other thing i would point out is
um
the rules that determine how people
interact
uh come in a few forms so there's laws
where
we have this idea that like laws are
very strong and if they're
uh violated they will be
enforced by some form of punishment or
fines or there's there's some kind of
enforcement there
but most of what people
do in the offline world is not just
skirting the edge of what's legal or not
there are also social norms around like
what is acceptable behavior
and how do i want to behave amongst
other people and
i pick up cues from others around me so
even if things aren't
illegal i won't necessarily do them
much easier to shout some on twitter
than actually look someone in the eye
and say the same thing
most of the stuff like for example the
people that would hate on hillary
clinton
i would just beg many of them to look
her in the eyes human being and say that
because hillary is a very impressive
person right like and
you know like his stuff you know is that
what you're saying yeah so i'm saying
like
there is there's a stuff that should be
clearly delineated as this is not
acceptable and if you
if you violate these rules there will be
repercussions to it
there's that set of things that uh we
probably need to be a bit stronger on
right now there's very little governance
of anything happening online the
consequence is just being an [ __ ] on
the internet
and the fact that like even some of the
things that are delineated is not
acceptable
don't get enforced that way means that
people implicitly
understand that they can still get away
with doing things that are not
so it's frowned upon slap on their
wrists outside of things but
i think there's also quite a bit that we
need to do in terms of setting better
norms online so maybe it's not
enforceable
anyway but it's enforceable in the sense
of like the community may shun you or
you may be looked down upon or like
we evolve social norms that are just
better for interacting with each other
and sure there may be some range of what
people
personally find acceptable or not um
like
just like in the offline world you'll
see people who are
nicer or ruder and it's all like within
some
general distribution of like what is
appropriate social behavior
check my future of censorship for
example censorship maybe that's defining
like
the absolute worst things that you're
not allowed to say
but i think that's a very limiting way
of looking at
all of our online systems and how people
interact and our participants in a
digital ecosystem a digital society
it's not just defined by what are the
worst things that you're not allowed to
do
but also like where are the norms what
are people expecting
in terms of interaction with each other
words is socially acceptable behaviors
on the internet
and right now it's the wild west well
there's nothing that's technically not
socially acceptable because everything
is
it's just it's just a mess um where like
there's stuff you say online you could
never get away with in person because
whether it's common sense or common
decency or whatever we've all agreed to
as like rule of law and like social
norms it's unacceptable
you mentioned this idea of like the wild
west i think that's a very good
metaphor to use as well when you look at
the lack of enforcement but lack of laws
and justice
and in that environment we kind of see
mob just as a vigilante justice and i
think
what people often will call cancel
culture fits into that where
because there's no real system of
enforcement that we can trust like
there's no law enforcement that we
think will in most cases when there are
violations like go
and follow through on the enforcement
um we end up having individual citizens
piling on to one person who does
something that's
deemed not acceptable and the punishment
in those cases ends up often being
pretty disproportionate to what the
original
supposed crime was and
it just feels very imperfect because you
do want there to be some accountability
and so you you get the sense of like
okay this person said something was very
inappropriate they did something that
was inappropriate
they should be held to account but
because there's not a good system of
justice when you have the huge pileup
from the entire internet it does feel
a little bit over the top and so we go
from like no accountability to way too
much accountability in certain cases in
most cases none
and i think the solution is not like
let's get rid of accountability
it's like how do we design a better
system of governance and law
and enforcement so that the
accountability is commensurate with
like if you made a terrible tweet
in your teens if you
behaved inappropriately at a party there
are consequences for those actions
and they should exist does it mean that
you should be unemployable the rest of
your life
um except by like far right-wing
organizations like probably not
right like that's we all make mistakes
hell i do
all the time and i'm sure i'll be
canceled over and over and that's it's
frustrating um and then on the other
hand it's like
okay but harvey weinstein was a disaster
so that guy needs to go to
like you know so there's like there is a
middle ground which the internet doesn't
really like to have right now we don't
really love nuance um
let me ask you this i'm just gonna come
off as an [ __ ] question so i'm going
to preface it by saying
i'm asking this in the in a human way as
nicely as i can
do you think we're too sensitive as a
society particularly on the internet in
the sense of
like i grew up like sticks and stones
when i break my bones when names will
never
hurt me right like we're all out here
and people are like i'm getting bullied
or there's harassment but the rowdy is
like
it's just dumb people saying mean things
the type of person it takes to say some
of the comments you were mentioning that
harassed you like
to me i'm like oh who cares about that
person he's clearly or she
probably usually he a sociopath pay them
no mind move on
and on so that's like where maybe
sometimes i lean but other times we have
people going the complete opposite like
this is a travesty we have to always
stand
have we built ourselves up to be too
sensitive
to overreact to time like what are your
thoughts on kind of our
the general sensitivity level
of your internet users and the press i
think too
i think there's um
kind of subtext to this question which
is the context
and a collapse of context um
and when you frame that question you
pose that question i immediately think
of different people's reactions to
certain things given what context they
are in
so for example if we're talking about
like negative comments
um maybe one negative comment
you can brush off and it's not that big
a deal you can just say like
ignored the trolls um
when it happens every day
all day it's very difficult to shake
that off
and i think when you have folks who
don't experience
the sort of like persistent harassment
only looking at individual examples the
response to just shake it off
is not understanding the context of like
dealing with this nonstop um
and i think there is a very real mental
health impact
and um it it's maybe a bit more
understandable for folks who have dealt
with it a lot to
to say like when you point out one bad
tweet
just shake it off or you see what's in
my timeline right now like you shake
this off [ __ ] like
yeah so there's a pretty big difference
there like
i could show you a couple of the the
tweets i've had to see over the last
couple of days and
they might all seem fine um
or like it's easy to brush it off but in
the context of like dealing with this
for
i don't know how many like over 10 years
and a lot of it and sometimes it's huge
pylons
um it it feels very different
another analogy i have heard sometimes
is like um
if somebody steps on your foot by
accident and you respond really
negatively
they may say like why are you so upset
like why are you so sensitive
like i just accidentally stepped on your
foot like you don't even like get upset
at me
but if you're the person whose foot got
stepped on and you've been stepped on
like thousands of times and your foot is
sore already
then when this other person like
accidentally steps on you
it already hurts and it's a huge pattern
of problematic behavior and hurt that
you have accrued
and so the responses feel different and
they feel mismatched and like both sides
may
feel upset at the other because
they're just operating from different
contexts i think that is important to
call it we have such different
experiences and
maybe something that's worse about um
the online world is that
it can be harder to understand what
someone else is dealing with
so i don't know what your notifications
look like on twitter you don't know what
mine look like
it's harder for me to have an
understanding of what you may be dealing
with or for you
um likewise versus in the real world if
we're sitting in the same room
or we're standing in the same room and i
see a bunch of people that come over to
you and are shouting me things i can get
a sense of like you're dealing with a
lot right now
and it's harder to see that online or
you can't
see dms very easily um of other of other
folks online
so these private messages these direct
messages they're meant to be one-on-one
communication so nobody else has access
to
what you're seeing and so you don't
really know like
what other crap somebody is dealing with
privately
versus in the offline world when when
people are harassing me on the street
the passersby can kind of see if there's
somebody there they can overhear
the shouting or that kind of thing um so
a lot of this context collapses
online so we just had this woman on um
sherry turkle man trying to define her
career so
but she's just done so many re so much
research i'm assuming you're familiar
with there's so much research on the
human side of tech and she said empathy
is not just
um putting yourself in someone's shoes
is putting yourself in someone's problem
um and that's the point of the context
you're talking about where it's not just
the one-off tweets it's that
for a number of people that these
the sheer volume of people making these
comments over days weeks months years
maybe a whole lifetime
becomes its own version of a problem um
and that to me it's a that's a really
really um
it's a compelling point i haven't i
haven't thought about um
and i think it's this is this piece of
empathy that a lot of us need to
start having and even these social norms
online right where this is the new
the new version of our our
irl if you will as we start to go online
um
so thank you for answering that my
[ __ ] question if you will in terms of
your perfect world in terms of how we
i'm gonna use the word sensor but it's
the wrong way but like censor and filter
out
harassment and hate speech and things
like that on the internet
what does it look like if we nail it and
what does it look like if we go too far
right because i know you know you're
dealing with the double-edged sword here
um and it's not clear it's not your job
as an entrepreneur to like regulate this
but i'm really curious your opinion is
someone who's on the front lines of this
so if we go too far
and if we nail it what do those look
like in your eyes
i think there's a few things that need
to happen across the ecosystem so it's
not just
a block party solution or like the
platform solution
it is what i was referring to earlier
with this like whole system of
governance that we need
i think the ideal case is we figure out
a new way of
governance a new way of establishing
social norms
where we realize all this promise of the
internet and connectivity and anybody be
able to reach anybody else
and the democratization of information
of access
um really smart people interesting
people being able to connect with others
and have really
creative innovations and reimaginations
of
human condition like all there's all
that good stuff that we've been promised
with the internet
um and the best case is we figure out a
new system of governance that
enables that and it will probably have
some form of
accountability where we've defined what
is not acceptable what is and when
things are done that are unacceptable
there are repercussions that are
commensurate with how bad
those things were that happened so
there's kind of that
infrastructure that needs to exist that
spans across different platforms across
the internet
um and it also has to
overlay with the offline world so
you can't get away with just doing some
stuff online and then it turns into
offline world harm and then you can kind
of
side step by the by like avoiding
jurisdictions
so that's the best case infrastructural
solutions um building on this knowledge
a little bit like public infrastructure
and private solutions i think where
block party fits right now is uh
when public infrastructure isn't quite
there yet
we still need to keep working on that
but in the meantime we build private
solutions for it
so an analogy might be um for public
safety
and transit sometimes when i'm trying to
go home
late at night i don't feel super safe
taking public transit uh like waiting at
the bus stop in the dark i don't feel
that great about it
and so the bigger problem is that
public infrastructure and safety isn't
there and so we need to advocate for
that to be fixed and there are policy
solutions
and funding issues uh that need to go
into that
but in the meantime as a private citizen
i can also appeal to private sector
solutions
uh so i can call a car service or a taxi
and get myself home safely
and so it doesn't mean that we can only
work on one of those at a time
but it is important that we give people
more solutions a block party is like
that private
solution for defense and safety
while we're working on the broader
public the ecosystem
keep up with you guys yeah so we need
both
um one thing i don't like about for
example like in the sort of like transit
analogy
one thing i don't like about car
services
that take over infrastructure of a city
is that then there's under investment in
the public services like i don't want
that either so you want to have
both of these things um and i think
there is a lot of room for
public private collaboration um
and a more creative reimagining of how
these things can fit together
i recently read mariana mazucato's book
mission economy
which i have not read it but i have it's
really great the hype
yes yes i really like the way we
that she presents of um thinking about
public private partnerships
and how it's not just this model of like
everything as a marketing economy and
the government is only here to fix
things that are broken like when
externalities aren't captured
the mark the the government will come in
and fix it um
or regulate when some things are broken
you can actually have them work together
to achieve much greater things
than just the market or just the
government alone and
um like the example she sides is like
with
um putting man on the moon like that yes
that was not gonna happen with like with
just a market economy or like just the
government
you need these to come together and i
think where we are a lot of the
challenges facing
humanity at the moment we need that kind
of um
broader thinking and mission alignment
we've talked about the injuries that uh
the government's terrible at many many
things but there are certain things
particularly let's call it climate
change and ai and
regulation the internet and maybe our
press at certain points like
if the government does nothing we're
toast the government has to lead
they have to infrastructure like they
have to um what do we like about
problems too big um so
here's the one thing it gives me hope um
i'm actually curious i'll probably send
you
what is giving you hope one thing gives
me hope is millennials
as parents um because one of the
if you're talking about social norms on
the internet um
usually that comes from a community and
a home
and being raised how your parents taught
you how your older siblings and things
like that taught you
and a lot of us like for me and probably
you growing up like you created an
online account or social media account
and your parents were so behind the
curve they have no idea what you're
doing
online they can't parent to you on the
internet
um but over time i think our generation
will
somewhat keep up with their kids and
understand what they can do on the
internet and improve that so that gives
me hope in terms of establishing norms
the internet maybe that's too optimistic
what gives you hope
in this space you just kind of touched
on a few things but i'm curious if you
had to wrap it up
the fact that the internet has allowed
people to connect in ways that weren't
possible before and you see this
especially amongst activists the people
who are pushing for change
and whereas these people previously may
have been minorities
in their communities and not been able
to connect with others who
would share their values and share that
passion for driving things forward it is
possible now to find
those peers and we're seeing
those people be able to come together
and organize um
and it is very hard to see youth
activists
who are so smart so insightful way
beyond what i could have
what was i doing as a kid on the
internet definitely not organizing
movements
so i think that is very powerful that
people can be connected so this is that
promise of the internet
um that we were sold a few decades ago
you're sold utopia there's definitely a
bunch of negative things that'll come
alongside that and one of the
unfortunate things see
for example the youth activists that a
lot of them are dealing with a ton of
abuse and harassment
that is intended to drive them off um
off of their platforms and derail them
from what they're trying to achieve
but it is really nice to see that there
is organization
happening and um i personally have felt
very lucky able to connect with other
folks uh
in doing diversity equity inclusion work
um
i feel like my life is a lot richer now
that i have access to so many more
people even if it's just following folks
on twitter and seeing
there's a stream of conscious like
random thoughts that they're sharing
throughout the day
it gives me so much more perspective
than would have ever been possible
previously when i would only ever be
regularly exposed to a handful of people
in my orbit that i interact with
normally
but now like i log into twitter and all
day long i can see
perspectives of folks from all around
the world very different environments
different very
very different lived experiences um
and that is that's pretty cool
i just to have that simulation um
to have my assumptions challenge all the
time and also one of the great things
about
um well social media sharing you can see
all the other people's um
lives it doesn't necessarily even
require that much work from them like so
they don't have to be educating me
one-on-one i can just like follow them
and get a bunch of their insights for
free which is amazing they educate you
without
without having to pay attention to you
or whatever right i don't
put the burden on them to teach me what
their experience is like if they're
willing to share i mean obviously it's
still taking some work for them to
share their experiences but
it's a much more leveraged way of doing
so like i can
follow trans activists and
understand that experience without
necessarily having to go like bother
people in my community tell me
like what is your life like what are the
issues you deal with like
what are you thinking when you deal with
these situations i can just get access
to all these like really
smart people or like um well
the black lives matter activists over
the last like year
um i feel like i can do a lot more
education work that is
passive on the activist part but i can
learn a lot from them
without them having to do a bunch of
individual education work for me
you're so right that the internet has
given a voice to a number
of people that just typically were just
voiceless
in in a lot of um particularly new and
exciting innovations or technologies or
when things are changing
um and the other thing look to your
point earlier is like one of the things
so
i'm on twitter only 11 of voters i guess
is the number i have but a very like a
small percentage of people are actually
on twitter and
even smaller percentage of that actually
comment so it's one of the things i
i like listening to where the activists
are saying but i also
hope that someday um it's one of the
things i did a lot of work in the autism
community
um when i was at ubs and you had your
autism activists
and then you had just families that
didn't particularly speak up a lot but
they had um and
they didn't always agree and i think to
your point like if you can make
more of these social norms on the
internet you can get the
voices of the activists that in many
cases have not been heard and also
voices of people that don't consider
themselves an activist actually never
really speak up but
have some really interesting
perspectives that no one's hearing
um and that's where frankly the work
you're doing to frankly create a safer
spot for people to talk
and your point your fascinating point is
that there's a certain element of
silencing freedom of speech when people
are afraid to say stuff because of
harassment
um and no matter what side of the aisle
you on that
is uh fundamental to free speech um
you know so tracy man i love doing these
conversations because i
when i learn a lot and i feel like
they're like three four times you keep
me in the side of the head with
something and i'm
in a healthy way so thank you where can
our listeners find and download your app
uh so we're at blockpartyapp.com it's a
web app so you don't need to download
anything just go to blockpartyapp.com
you can find us on twitter at
blockpartyapp underscore
thank you from the bottom of my heart
and um
keep doing what you are doing
and i hope um you feel somewhat
encouraged after this conversation
i feel more hopeful so thank you um but
blockpartyapp.com
tracy chow you are a superstar
thank you for joining yang speaks the
future of censorship
thank you for having me it's very fun to
have this conversation
you